حسنًا ، هذا الصباح ، تهاجم
أوكرانيا روسيا التي تلقي باللوم على أوكرانيا في هجوم بطائرة بدون طيار
أصاب ناقلة نفط بالقرب
من أحد مهابطها الجوي ، وقد حدث هذا بين عشية وضحاها
، وحدث ذلك في منطقة كورسك
بالقرب من الحدود الشمالية الشرقية لأوكرانيا.
قواعد عميقة داخل روسيا ،
لذلك دعونا نتحدث إلى الرائد في الجيش الأمريكي المتقاعد ،
صباح الخير
لك ، ما أجده مثيرًا للاهتمام حول
تحليلك لهذا هو أنك تقول إن
أوكرانيا تحاول إرسال رسالة دون إعلان
صراحة مسؤوليتها ، نعم
أعتقد أنها  إستراتيجية لها
آثار إستراتيجية للغاية ، حقيقة أن
لديهم هذه القدرة
ويظهرونها الآن أمر مهم للغاية
رقم واحد ثم ثانيًا حقيقة
أن هذه الطائرات بدون طيار قد مرت
عبر منصات الدفاع الجوي الروسية التي
لم نسمع بها من قبل.
أيام الحرب الباردة في حلف الناتو ، لم يكن من
الممكن أخيرًا من الناحية النفسية
حقيقة أن أوكرانيا يمكنها أخذ هذه
الطائرات بدون طيار 197  تجرد تقنية 0s
الكاميرات وتزيل كل تلك الأشياء الموضوعة
في مرسوم وتضع
القدرة على أنه من الصعب
إصابة هدف من مسافة 700 كيلومتر ، لذا
يمكنك أن تشرح لنا ميزة Advantage Ukraine في هذا الأمر.
يحدث وماذا عن الهجمات التي حدثت في
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع وبعد ذلك بين عشية وضحاها
تظهر لنا هاتين القاعدتين الجويتين هنا حيث
كانت الأهداف قاذفات استراتيجية ،
هذه هي القاذفات الاستراتيجية التي لا
تذهب في أوكرانيا لأنهم لا
يسيطرون على المجال الجوي الذي لا تسيطر عليه روسيا
هناك لذلك كانوا
يهاجمون بهذه الطريقة في هذا الاتجاه
هنا ولكن الحقيقة هي 700 كيلومتر أو نحو ذلك
هنا 600 كيلومتر من هذا الجانب
هنا والآن موسكو مهددة من الناحية النظرية
الآن هذان
هدفان عسكريان هناك دعنا نوضح أنهما
عسكريان شرعيان  السياحة ، هذا هو المكان
الذي يأتون منه ، حيث
تأتي القاذفات التي
تهاجم أوكرانيا ولكن مرة أخرى ،
الخلاصة أنه من الصعب حقًا إرسال
صاروخ 700 كيلومتر.  ters وضرب
مطارًا كما فعلوا ، فهذا شيء
جديد تظهر أوكرانيا أنه يمكنها
تنفيذه ، وإذا كان الأمر كذلك ، فأنت تعتقد أن
هذا تدريب جديد من الغرب جيدًا
أعتقد أن الكثير منه يتعلق
بالتكنولوجيا التي  لقد أحضرت
وأعتقد أن بعضًا منها نحن الولايات المتحدة التي
تقولها الولايات المتحدة
ودعنا نسميها الغرب ولكن من المحتمل أيضًا
أن يكون هناك شخص ما على
الأرض يرسم ذلك الهدف عندما تنظر
إلى تلف الطائرة على سبيل المثال هذا هو
a tu
22m3 a backfire bomber old الناتو
هذا هو هذا كوكب روسي الصنع
يمكنك أن تعرفه من خلال ضوء الذيل هذا هنا
هذا هو نوع الضرر
الذي يمكن أن نستهدفه عن كثب بالنسبة لي يقول
شخص ما كسل أنه كان للغاية
دقيقة مرة أخرى ، من الصعب حقًا أن تقطع
تلك المسافة وتضرب شيئًا ما في هذا
المطار ، حيث يتعين
على روسيا الآن أن تفكر في
الأهداف العسكرية الأقرب إلى الحدود الأوكرانية
كما رأينا هذا الصباح
عندما نشاهد حقول النفط من هذا النوع.  سيكون عدد
الأهداف الآن جاهزًا للخريجين
، وسيتعين على الروس
إعادة اختراع جيشهم للدفاع عنها ،
هل يمكنهم إعادة اختراع جيشهم في
منتصف هذا الأمر جيدًا ،
سيضطرون على الأرجح إلى إعادة نشر
القوات مرة أخرى إلى  حماية الوطن الأم
هنا في هذه المرحلة مع العلم جيدًا
أن أوكرانيا لديها هذه القدرة ،
شكرًا لك زبائني الرئيسيين ، شكرًا لك